yo man I remember reading about it was
it was either Brad Pitt or Angelina
Jolie I can't remember which one but one
of them was on set for the love scene
really yeah it kind of like I go ahead
and do and watch your [ __ ] hands like
that's like Oh No yeah i was i was
thinking myself like you know i did
marry an actress you know what plan what
would I be willing to let go right I
mean depending on how your girl gets how
big she gets you know it was like yours
these actresses that make it big and
then they do something really [ __ ] no
I gotta like oh what's her name boom
basic instinct you know I'm Sharon Stone
yeah yeah she's got the whole long legs
uncrossing dangle yo you know what I
found out about that the ifl I found out
I just saw a video for it I'm gonna be
posting my reaction to it she was told
by the director that her underwear is
interfering with the lighting so to take
up and she was confused so she's like
all right I'll take off my underwear and
then he got the shot of her vagina he
did not tell her that so when the movie
came out she was shocked and pissed off
so yeah everyone thought it was like an
intentional move like I thought it was
intentional for the longest time up
until like two days ago okay yeah I'd
never [ __ ] did it that changes things
Lou okay well then baby all right how
about the Saved by the Bell chick Oh
showgirls yeah you know and the or they
all end up showing their kits at one
point yeah buddy Oh would you deal with
that if she wanted to well there's he
seemed like she filmed this movie before
we got together so I'm like all right I
can let things go but then although she
did okay then I'm thinking what if she's
now we're together
you know like because you do see here
did you see her breasts in this movie
and oh he hurt the other boobs for tips
the knockers and you see them in the
movie and at one point a guy like it
even squeezes them and look at that
problem no no look at your watch i wrote
i want you to leave i want no yeah i
mean it's it's that's another emotional
process like the first day like when i
first saw the movie with her she was on
edge because she was like so
uncomfortable watching this in a theater
her dad's like two seats over her and
stuff oh yeah so it was like a
nerve-wracking so I wasn't even thinking
about me I was LA and I and she's so
good in the film that everyone i know is
saying the same thing you you completely
forget you're watching veronica like
she's fantastic in and she's my
girlfriend and even I was like like
tripping out because I'm like I don't
see my girlfriend anymore in this movie
but when I got home that [ __ ] really
bothered me like I just go yeah it was
like why would you expose me to that
funny so I was being like a little brat
about everything but it's it's
challenging it's something like the last
time I saw you know you kind of just
whatever about it but you know it's
something you got to get past I suppose
but it's like was that line between
cheating though you know like good if
it's for her job that doesn't mean it's
not cheating is it you know like it's
for the ignored so this and so I kind of
feel like it's not an open relationship
but for her job it's kind of an open
relationship good so yeah like you know
what I've always told myself that I
don't I try
if I start dating a girl that was doing
something before I met her then I need
to accept this for the most part yes of
course oh I I don't like like if I'm
looking at girls online you know I don't
like girls that take pictures with all
the cleavage and ass in the air and [ __ ]
like that you know because to me it's
[ __ ] and most people aren't going to
respect the woman so if i get with you
knowing that your [ __ ] I'm not calling
you go slowly but yeah I'm talking about
something that they do that I don't in
particularly a free with beforehand
that's the whole point that I can't
complain yeah yeah yeah i mean i can
maybe I can change it make that give
request no more new things do you
understand me you know cuz there's a lot
of actresses that whoa yeah Jennifer
Aniston she did a movie where she did
show her tits and I caught that pretty
screen I actually caught that screening
but uh she but when she got with her
boyfriend she said I want that scene cut
out because it's disrespectful to my
boyfriend and so they actually cut it
out but I still gotta see Jennifer
essence it's a lot of people didn't but
I didn't so yeah well you know it's one
of those things where it depends on your
perception some people look at it more
as art then just a movie yeah because
you know I'm like a big movie buff and I
understand the whole art behind it so
it's like I'm conflicted because it's
like I also completely get the other
side as well so it's like I have my
insecure feelings and then I have the
understanding of it too so you can fo
eyes now that we've said in this energy
of that Veronica's pits are shown in
this movie you do realize that so I'm
trying to sell tickets IRA oh good the
movie theaters gonna be bad yeah wicked
no I mean yeah
it's like it whatever sells cuz I know
they're gonna walk out thinking she did
a great job anyway so yeah wait a minute
you living out of LA do you like no porn
stars I've never actually I meet people
who know porn stars like often it's a
weird thing but I don't know any porn
stars not not not one and I would like
to get to know I have hookers outside of
my apartment not even joke I believe it
there's actual like disgusting-looking
hookers out there not Hollywood hookers
they're like disgusting like oh my god
you're a walking STD kind of the curse
but I I don't actually know any porn
stars or anything like that I've even
met a guy who was about to jump into
porn like he was ready and everything
and he had the meeting set up so yeah
porn is pretty popular out here to rise
and I and I make a lot of jokes the porn
kind of [ __ ] me up growing up um like
I make a lot of jokes about porn it's
one of those things were like how do I
put it like my some of my favorite
comedians are people like Louie CK whoo
hoo boo hoo maybe uses like struggles
are going through or insecurities or
emotional things and they use it as an
outlet through comedy and I do that so
if I make jokes about porn it's what I'm
doing um but like it my dad just making
my family look great right now no I have
a lot I love my family I really do love
my family like we've been a lot closer
than ever but my dad was into porn a lot
and this was before the internet so
there was there was like a [ __ ] ton of
like the first porno I saw I was like I
must have been like what um nine years
old and it was this chick holding two
guys dicks and they were coming on her
face and I'm like I'm like this
nine-year-old kid watching this and then
when I time I'm 12 i'm watching like a
hawk
it was 50 guys on one side 50 guys
another side there in a line and this
one chick and they're all taking turns
coming on her and when you're you got to
imagine if you if you see a little boy
looking at something like that it's
gonna [ __ ] up their brain you know
exactly so I've had to do a lot like
that's why therapy is really come in
handy too is like you know that I used
to now we're gonna get into romantic
tears or yeah I I never was able to in a
plus I I grew up I'm not Catholic
anymore but I grew up Catholic I went to
Catholic school and everything and I was
at poor kid in Catholic school the one
where the parents were really struggling
to keep him and so I went to Catholic
school any know how they were about sex
and masturbation like you shouldn't do
it it's all sin so don't do it um so
when I started like becoming an adult
and started getting all these like
natural biological reactions of like
getting horny and [ __ ] when it came to
sex I I eat or anything or anything
sexual I could never associate it
properly with someone I actually had
feelings for it was always separate like
I don't I truthfully didn't know what it
was like to make love like actually like
make love with a woman not [ __ ] a girl
but like may club until Veronica it was
the weirdest thing and that's when i
read it was like after every connection
we had and then we had that there was
like the that's when I was like oh my
god this is this is what making love
feels like and it was so different but
because of more like really if it costs
such a disassociation with an emotional
connection for me you know right does it
not really brief you know it's not real
it's rough and it's like you're watching
intense graphic images with a developing
brain he now so it's it's like you're
just absorbing all this [ __ ] I mean I
wonder how to [ __ ] from porn and I'm
pretty good at that but other than that
it's you know I never he s until I
started watching bangbros yeah
it always looked like it was really
worked on the girls evane gross so I was
like oh sorry i'll do it out the word
wait you saw I you saw the 10 discussing
reveal that the disgusting things about
the foreign ministry no porn starts
avail I cannot believe the amount of
[ __ ] story server I should have reacted
to that video you and Noel but she was
funnier than you were because she was
like relating to the [ __ ] and like yeah
your eyes when she said I think I
watched some of her for good okay yeah
no man don't know I'll cracks me up but
now thats that stuff like was like damn
i've seen so much port of like anal sex
and then suddenly I'm like how many
times you [ __ ] things go now it's kind
of like I used to want to try it now I'm
like I don't know man for me it does
nothing for the anal does nothing for me
it's a one-way street team yeah it's
whatever I don't have to do whatever jen
i was she asks girl ask me i'm gonna i'm
going to tell you a story real fast all
right